salut romandie dont je fais quoi saint
jean n'a rien pourquoi alors tu réserves
qu'ont 22 23 et 24 du maine en croisière
non pas vraiment l'année dernière je
suis allé au hellfest
d'ailleurs j'ai croisé pas mal d'entre
vous et c'était très tranquille c'était
tellement cool que cette année les
belges y retourne et j'y retourne avec
romain et d'ici là on va vous faire une
série de vidéos avec mes petits conseils
pour bien préparer l'événement alors
même si vous vous comptez pas y aller je
vous conseille d'être attentif parce que
ce qu'on va vous raconter c'est valable
pour tous les autres festivals estivaux
c'est là pour tous les faits stoch et de
toute façon c'est toujours bon à savoir
mais comme on parle bien que de ce qu'on
connaît vraiment je vais vous parler du
hajj est la fête la musique les
activités récréatives
les animations sportives les rencontres
les danses folkloriques mais aussi la
chaleur et le soleil de l'été qui débute
autant de petits et de grands bonheurs
dont il faut absolument profiter à fond
pendant un deux trois voire quatre jours
sur place et qui veut voyager loin
ménage sa monture
alors soyons clairs je vais vous parler
de santé mais tout ça c'est extrêmement
festif
le hellfest c'est ultra bon enfant c'est
jovial les gens font attention les uns
aux autres comme dans une grande famille
donc aucun souci
évidemment derrière en termes de
sécurité de secouriste et ses terrasses
et du top niveau mais ça on en reparlera
mais c'est comme pour toutes les
compétitions sportives si on veut être
au top le jour j
l'important c'est la prépa ration parce
que ce serait quand même qu'on les faire
un petit pépin physique gâcher un truc
qu'on attend toute l'année donc d'ici
fin juin je vais vous faire plusieurs
vidéos pour bien préparer l'événement on
va parler de headbanging on va parler de
la trousse de secours à emporter avec
vous et on va parler de tout ce qu'il
faut faire et de tout ce qu'il faut pas
faire avant et pendant pour passer le
d'ailleurs fait est possible et
évidemment si vous avez des questions
vous l'envoyez intimes est la question
dtc @ gmail point com on est parti pour
faire un bon petit bout de chemin
ensemble donc on est là dessus
[Musique]
m
ah oui en attendant bas mettez vous bien
et surtout portez vous dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]